on the hill today for the giants will be
the veteran jeff samaraja samarja 64 235
pounds he's in his 11th year at the big
league level he's 35 years of age and
it'll be chew to lead things off against
samarja the payoff
got him
from 3-0 to a strikeout
just
showed a cutter on the 3-1 pitch and
then came back with it again
but he just took a little off and that's
really nice touch for a power arm
calhoun is the
designated hitter and he hits a high
drive into right center field moving
back to slater still moving back way out
into triples alley makes the catch and
that's going to end the inning
calhoun
just got oracle
let's go ahead and take a look at the
pitch arsenal for the ranger starter
today brought to you by steele it's
colby allard 14 fastball cutter change
up interesting that chris woodward
talked about his curveball even though
he only used it five percent of the time
last year so two down and here is mike
yesgrenski
2-2
swung on and missed strike three so a
scoreless 1-2-3 for colby allard joey
gallo leading it off
this one away and gallow tries to serve
that over short he does base hit
joey is aboard to start the second
inning
one strike offering to solace and this
one
smashed and in the left field base hit
that one well struck and a couple of
base runners now
scott heinemann will bat now with a man
on scoring position
in the pitch he hits his ball well
out to left field that's a long run
pence won't get to it it's down
gallow is in solac to third base they
wave him to the plate he'll score
heinemann with a two run double
and so the rangers again jump out in
front this afternoon
in san francisco and this ball
absolutely ripped here's jeff mathis
runner goes this bulb in the air out
toward left field pence coming on can't
get it heinemann around 30 scores
three-nothing rangers on top mathis
keeps his perfect season alive and
here's hunter pence who
pence drives one
deep into right center field this is
going to be his first hit and let's see
if he ears it out he hits the bag at
third at second he's headed to third and
he's gonna make it
and the dugout erupts now here is
longoria who's been swinging a great
back
out into right center field this will be
good enough to score pence
as heinemann makes the catch giants are
on the board on the sacrifice fly
two down nobody on yastremski
and he struck him out twice today
so colby allard excellent start to the
ball game went through three innings
pops him up
should be a play for frasier
but he's doing the pop-up dance and it's
a fair ball but an infield fly rule was
called well the rule is npo fly batters
out advance
at your own risk so the good part of
this play was once it hit the ground
evan longoria at second base he took off
giant starting pitchers this season
first time since 1893 when the mound was
moved to its current distance from home
plate that any major league team
starters have not gone further than four
and a third innings in any of its first
nine games
well jeff samarza has a chance to end it
right here
and a line drive to right field and a
base sit
here's
chew looks like they want this one up oh
get up and chew liked it there hammers
that one deep to right that could be wet
it's gone
into mccovey's cove
a two-run blast by chew
his second home run of the year and he
has stretched the rangers lead
to five to one
jazz struck out twice against the
left-hander allard now facing the
right-hander jabot
on the ground up to middle
it's gonna give the giants a run
ski with the ground out in the rbi
flores goes to third here's longoria oh
for one with a sacrifice fly
high drive to left
chewbacc
looking up out of here
first of the year
get that pretty good he got both cheeks
into that bad boy
three and two
high fly ball to left
chew back at the wall
out of here
and this game is tied
his first major league home run ties the
game
here in the sixth inning
the giants have walked the bases loaded
were walked loaded
in a tie game in seventh inning
calhoun in the air deep enough to get
home a run
tagging at third base mathis
chu moves up to third so a sac fly by
calhoun and the rangers back in front so
gallow one for two with a single and a
walk coming up with
a damage opportunity
this ball crushed out to right field
deepest part of the park it carries well
it's gone
right over the 415 marker in triples
alley
and gallow choose the biggest part of
the park to hit it out
two outs
giants down to their last out
as they wrap up this series after
dropping the first two
their strike three call boy he made very
light work of the giants in the ninth
inning and volquez
razors sharp
and finishes off a 9-5 rangers win